>> All right, it's
my great pleasure
to have Geoff Voelker
here, professor at UCSD.
I think everyone
knows who he is.
He's done an immense amount
of impactful work in
the area of security.
Very recently, he was
awarded The Test of Time
Award at USENIX security.
And also, last year he
became an ACM fellow.
Geoff has had a long history
with us at Microsoft,
he's a friend of ours.
He was the first intern in
the Systems Group here at MSR.
Since then, he has had a lot
of interaction with us,
both directly and also
indirectly through his students,
who have come and spent
a lot of time with us.
And Geoff has also
spent almost an
entire year in MSR India.
So, it's a great pleasure
to have our friend
here. Thank you.
>> Thank you very much.
Thank you, Charlie.
All right, are you guys
hearing through the mic?
Great. It's
fantastic to be here.
It's always fun to
come back to MSR.
I have many, many great
memories going all the way
back to when I was an intern and
when everything was just
getting started here.
And even when I was
a super green professor,
just starting at UCSD.
Victor helped me out
a lot with both support,
and advice, and mentorship.
So, I have
a very close and personal
history with Microsoft.
What I want to do
today is talk about
some relatively recent work
that we've been
doing in sort of this
cybercrime space.
We call it
Evidence-Based Security.
And we call this Center
because the NSF style
funding, that it is.
But it's essentially
a large grant from
NSF to do
cybercrime-related research.
And this is something that we
also work very closely with
Vern Paxson at Berkeley,
going all the way back to
way on, in previous projects.
And, the style of
security work that we
wound up doing over time,
sort of, evolved into this style
where, roughly speaking,
we do a tremendous amount
of measurement to be
able to understand the problem,
the attackers,
what they're doing,
how they're impacting users or
infrastructure, or whatever
is it they're doing.
And then, when thinking about
how to both understand and
potentially undermine and deal
with some style of abuse
or large-scale attack,
to also not just think about
technical approaches
but also sort of
the economics and
social aspects of the attack,
as well, as additional leverage
for trying to impact
what's going on.
And then, finally to
engage with attackers
where possible.
And so, in the set of
work that we've done,
the stuff that's
probably most well-known,
that we've given
lot to talk about,
is all this spam work,
where we are going after
email spam and eventually search
spam and we bought
a lot of drugs
for science and
all this crazy stuff.
But in reality, actually,
we've done lots of
different things over time.
Many, many different kinds
of cybercrime-related work.
The stuff that I highlighted
in blue are actually
projects that we worked
together with Microsoft.
We have a number of
projects that we've done
with PsyCAT in particular.
But also the Digital Crime Unit,
when we were doing all of that,
that email spam,
and stuff like that.
So, it's been great working
with Microsoft on this style
of projects as well.
So, for today, I
wanted to cover sort of
two relatively recent projects.
They're not necessarily
tied together directly,
except that they are
relatively recent.
One is on something
that we call Tripwire,
which is sort of the mechanism
for being able to infer
site compromise externally
as a third party.
And then, the second
is an effort
looking at the main
motivation is to,
sort of, foundations for
looking at abuse related to DNS.
But starting out by exploring
what is happening with
the introduction of all of
these new top-level
domains in DNS.
And, if there's additional time,
probably not because I stuck
a lot of slides in here,
I can talk about where
we're going from here.
And at any point, please
feel free to stop me
if you have questions.
It's much more fun for me if
it's an interactive style talk.
Okay. So, I'll start with
the first project which was
led by our student Joe DeBlasio.
We have this system called
Tripwire for being able
to infer site compromise.
And, data breaches and
site compromises are
all over the news.
Everybody's been compromised
and I can absolutely
guarantee you the UCSD has
been compromised
many times over.
And, one question is,
how many compromises
are there out there?
And what is the rate?
Who is being compromised?
Potentially why?
All these interesting questions.
The challenge is trying to
measure this stuff externally,
because nobody wants to admit
that they've been compromised.
To me, it's analogous,
we did this very early
work back in 2001,
looking at denial
of service attacks.
Nobody wants to
admit they're being
attacked but can
you come up with
ways to infer this externally.
So, the idea that
we had was that,
we can get insight into
compromises at sites,
through the fact that people
re-use their passwords.
Okay. So in general,
the idea is that for
any arbitrary site out there,
let's say it's
even some hobby site,
users will sign up,
the site will ask the users
for their email address,
and then a password,
and then maybe
the credentials that they'll
use to log in to the site.
And the reason why
attackers might break into
a site, compromise it,
and then use the email account
and the password,
why it might have value to them,
is because, if there
is password re-use,
then they can go and try to log
in to the email account
of that user.
So, they breached
some other site over there,
which then led some leapfrog
into the Webmail account,
and then they have
all of these assets
associated with
that email account that they
can mine and try to monetize.
So there's actually
a lot of value.
So, when there are slight
compromises and data breaches,
particularly of the credentials,
attackers will routinely
just take all of
the the email accounts that
they find and the passwords,
and just try to see if they
can log into the email account.
And if so, they
will use it directly
or resell those email accounts
in bulk to other attackers.
There's a lot of value in
attackers being able to do this.
Okay, so then,
this sort of suggests,
a technique for being able to
detect site compromise
externally.
So, what I'll do is
talk about, sort of,
the methodology that we used,
and then a study that we did
over the span of
about a year-and-a-half,
talk about the compromises
that we detected.
And then, we did
an additional step,
where we contacted all the sites
where we detected compromise,
and sort of interacted with
them about what it
is that they found.
And it was actually pretty
eye-opening
that disclosure step.
Wasn't quite sure what
was going to happen.
>> Isn't that like when
you create a honey account?
>> Exactly, great.
Okay. So with this,
the idea is actually
very straightforward.
We're just going to partner with
a large Webmail provider,
who asked to remain anonymous.
And we're just going
to create a whole bunch
of honey email accounts.
And we're going to use
those email accounts
one-to-one with sites
out on the internet.
And then, we'll just wait.
Just wait, wait, wait.
Eventually, an attacker will
compromise one of the sites.
We don't know which
one, just going to wait.
And then, they'll try to log
in to an account at
the email provider.
And then, the email
provider is going to
be monitoring
all these accounts,
and will notify us if there
are any log in attempts,
whether they're
successful or not.
And then, potentially
even monitor
the activity of what
happens to those accounts
when somebody logs in.
Okay? That's the general idea.
Very straightforward.
>> Do you make the passwords
especially easy or something
to ensure that [inaudible].
>> Great question
and I'll give you $5.
Okay. So, when we registered
accounts of the sites,
we actually registered
two accounts.
One account that
had an easy to guess
password and another account
that had a hard
to crack password.
And then, when we looked to
see if there were log in
attempts to our accounts,
we looked to see whether or not
the attackers were
able to get in
to the easy account and
get in to the hard account.
And if they are able to
get into the hard account,
then that means that site did
not do a good job of
securing passwords.
They're either in the clear
or very easily reverse
engineered using rainbow tables
or any standard
method out there.
So, it lets us
differentiate and get
some insight into sort of
the security practices of
the site. Great question.
Exactly. Doing this for
one or two sites,
very straightforward.
So, one of the technical
challenges was scaling this up,
so that we could just go
down lots of different sites
and try to register
accounts with them.
So, a lot of the work
that Joe had to do
was sort of building
an automated crawler to be able
to identify an account
registration page,
parse everything, and then
sign up for the account,
get the email message to
confirm the registration,
click on that, and all
that kind of stuff.
The pages tend to be written in
such a way to make it
hard to automate that,
because in a way,
large scale account
sign up is not
necessarily something that we
want to encourage or make easy.
And then, we also supplemented
the automated crawler,
which is going down to sites at
the top Alexa and
just doing manual registrations
if the crawler failed.
And then, the Webmail provider,
we generated the profiles
for all of the accounts,
the passwords, and
the account usernames.
And then, we would just give
that information to
the Webmail provider,
and then they would just
create accounts for us in bulk.
The Webmail provider did not
know which accounts we had
used or even which
sites those accounts
were associated with.
And what was nice about that,
is that, in the end,
we had about 100,000
of these honeypots accounts
that we didn't sign up anywhere.
And they were never accessed,
which gave us
a pretty good indication
that the Webmail provider
was not breached.
So, having our accounts
logged in to,
was not a result of
the Webmail provider
itself actually
getting breached.
Okay. So then, we
have this crawler,
we just go down
the Alexa rankings,
trying to identify sites
that we can register at.
For the sites that actually
had registration pages,
the automated crawler
succeeded reasonably well,
but it was focused
on English sites,
there are actually a lot
of non-English Sites
in the top Alexa.
And then, some sites that
were very difficult to do,
just using an automated crawler.
>> So, of those sites you said,
you succeeded about 20
percent of the time.
When you failed,
was it credit card?
Page part of credit card, or?
>> It was all sorts
of different things.
So, they might ask
for a credit card.
It might be a very
advanced capture where,
so to solve captures
we would just
enlist a capture solving
service and pay them.
And some of those
just couldn't handle,
the interface of using
the service couldn't
handle the advanced captures.
Sometimes sites will ask
for one bit of
information on one page.
Make you click, go to
another page, enter,
and the next bit
information, and so on,
and so forth, and
so this multi-step.
There are sites out there,
so for example, let's say
for power utility sites.
There's an account there,
but the only way in which you
can actually login and register,
is if you actually
have some kind of
relationship with them already,
and you can't just arbitrarily.
So, the bottom line
is there are lots of
different reasons,
why the automated
crawler would fail.
>> The power companies
are in an eligible case?
>> It would be
an eligible case, yeah.
So in the end, we were
able to successfully
register on 2,300 sites,
which was less than
we thought we were
going to be able to
do going into the project but,
still sort of, is a reasonably
sized number. And then-
>> If you studied this over,
if you would study this
over a period of time,
would you start to see that it's
getting harder or easier,
I would hope harder, to
create such accounts?
>> I think it's harder.
>> So the number 23,
like for example,
if you started to study
again for another two years,
it should come down too,
which is a good thing. Right?
>> It is a good thing,
but at the same time,
if we invested more effort
in our crawler,
then we can sort
of take no account,
and deal with
more sophisticated ways
of registering accounts.
So I think, we could
still sort of maintain it.
>> I guess my point was that,
so I'm sort of thinking like
long time back you might
remember when we were sort of
thinking about Wi-Fi, right?
Where everything was
accessible, but then,
everything came with default
passwords, it became difficult.
But then everything
was, you know, so
eventually, like it
kept going downward.
And so then, compromising
it became harder.
And so there was a lot
of papers written
in the past saying,
"Hey, you can
connect, and you can
do all this thing. But now."
>> Now it's not even an issue.
>> All that stuff is just gone.
>> I don't think this
is going to go away,
because the sort of
the counterbalance is that
sites in general
don't want to make it
too hard for people
to register accounts.
>> Right.
>> Particularly if
you're not a top site.
So you don't want
to make it hard and
push people away because
you want to attract people.
So that's why I think
it's going to balance out.
The end result of doing
the monitor is that we detected
19 site breaches which is
almost one percent of the sites
that we are monitoring,
which is actually more
than I thought we
were going to detect.
So now I'll talk
a little bit about, sort of,
characteristics of the sites
that we did detect
the breaches at.
So these are tables, we
just letter the sites,
A through S. The check mark
in the hard column means
that the honeypot account
that we had associated
with the site,
the attacker was able to
login using the hard password.
So that meant, you know,
bad practices on the site.
This is the yield,
the Alexa ranking,
sort of modular 500.
And then sort of the category of
the style of site that we see.
One nice little bit of
validation was that,
for all of these sites,
they had not been
confirmed to ever have been
compromised except
for bitcointalk.org.
They went public about
being compromised,
and we had already had
a honeypot account.
And we were able to confirm that
exactly when they said
they were compromised,
sure enough the next day,
somebody logged into
our e-mail account.
And they are very clear about,
sort of, what their practices
were in managing accounts,
and they did a good job in
keeping passwords encrypted,
and so we did not see
a login to our hard account,
hard password account.
>> So what's the question mark?
>> The question mark here is
that due to
methodological issues,
we only registered an easy
password account on that site.
We did not register
a hard one that
we did not- we only
discovered that afterwards.
And so we don't know.
That's why we leave
a question mark.
>> So when you checked,
that means the
hardware was like,
in the cases where
the hard password was tried,
was the easy one also tried?
>> In general yes,
both were tried.
Not always, but in general, yes.
>> So why, well,
why would one, not
the other fits?
>> Yeah, they're going through
all of the accounts sort
of systematically while,
when they do all of them.
I don't have
a good answer for that.
I think there was one situation,
one of the sites where the
easy account was
not logged into.
>> So just a clarification.
So when there is a compromise
using a hard password,
you're able to verify
that they weren't just
doing brute force attacks
of hard passwords.
It was just one login attempt
with the exact password.
>> Yeah. These were
not brute forced.
>> But the ones where there
isn't a hard check mark,
they tried to brute force?
Like, you could you could
see the brute force attack.
>> They were not doing
any- they were not brute
forcing account logins
at the webmail provider.
>> Okay.
>> What they were doing
is, they would take
the password database off
line and then they would
brute force it off line,
and then they would just use
what it is they discovered
as a single login
attempt. Successful.
>> So for 2,300 websites,
was there any public
compromise among them,
that you have account
and you didn't
see the e-mail account was used?
>> So there were no,
there were no sites that
had declared themselves
as being compromised where
we had an account
and did not see it.
So there were no, we
didn't miss anything,
there were no false negatives.
We didn't miss anything.
>> We should be talking
more about what about
these sites, you know, widely.
>> Yeah. And it's,
you know it's easy to imagine,
it's sort of a random
hobby site out there.
Doesn't have good security
practices and can be breached.
But for the sites we're in,
the Alexa top 500 in
their home country.
So even top sites
like the first one,
top 500 Alexa ranking,
billion dollar company, and
the hard password account
was accessed.
And then for these two,
they wound up being
the same company totaling,
comprising about 30
million users but
only the easy password
was accessed there. Yes.
>> So when the easy
password was accessed,
your hypothesis is that it was
just an online guessing attack
at the site in question, right?
>> Offline guessing, until they
had figured out passwords,
and then they would just use
those passwords at
the webmail provider.
>> For the weak password?
>> For the weak password, yes.
>> So why wouldn't you
assume that it was an online,
just a guessing attack
against the server,
and there was
no compromise other than,
like, how weak were
those passwords?
>> I see. So the question is,
for the sites that
were compromised,
were those sites brute
forced externally?
>> No. The question
is for the ones,
for the sites where
the weak account was taken,
are you saying that it was,
are you suggesting
that that account was
compromised because
somebody guessed and
password was so easy that
it was guessable online?
Or that there was breach with
the server and they got
under the knife like-
>>So that would
be a possibility,
which is that the account was so
easy that they would just
go to the webmail provider,
and just use,
guess very simply that
they could just login.
>> Yup.
>> There are two reasons why
we don't think
that was the case.
The first is that the webmail
provider check to see if there
is any sort of
brute force attempts
on any of the accounts,
multiple logins, before it
actually was successful.
>> Not but on
online attack at the site?
>> At the site.
>> They would have had to guess
his randomly generated
email address as well as-
>> That's what I'm getting to.
>> So all of our e-mail
addresses are private.
>> Okay, and they're
not super discoverable?
>> No.
>> That's good.
But they are
themselves constraints?
>> Yes. Yes, exactly. All right.
So this is, this just
shows sort of from
a timeline perspective what
the login activity it is
across the different sites.
So this is time on the x axis,
the different sites are
each a row going across.
And then we have two dots,
an open circle for
easy, orange for hard.
And it just shows
you, over time,
what the login activity across
the different sites were.
>> How many times?
>> And then, the number in
parentheses on the right,
y, is the is the number
of logins per site.
>> These are email logins?
>> Yes. So these are attackers
logging into
our e-mail accounts at
the webmail provider using
one of the two
different ones to-
>> And when did you ask?
So 7/15 is your first.
>> Yes.
>> And when did you first
set this whole thing up?
>> 7/15, I think was
three months after we started.
>> So what did you
think happened for
three months, nothing?
>> Well, we did have a gap
in that period where it could
have been that there are,
accounts had been compromised
and we didn't detect it.
I have no good
explanation for- but it's,
you know, we sorted them by
time of first account access.
And you do see that
there are gaps in
months before we detect
another compromise.
So it's going to be in
a month's time frame.
>> Kind of weird how-
>> Can I tell?
>> It looks like a month
when the compromise started.
>> Yeah, I don't want to read
too much in the tea leaves.
>> What are they doing
when they login, are
they sending spam?
>> I thought this
was going to be an
interesting part of the study,
which is looking to see
what the attackers did with
the accounts and
then we end up being
an uninteresting part
of the study.
There were a few where
the automated systems that
the webmail providers to shut
down the accounts because
they were sending out spam,
but by and large,
they would login, look
around, and just not do much.
And they're doing
this multiple times.
So, I just don't know. I think.
>> It's not that much
in the email inbox.
>> We did not. But
it's clear that
they were logging in
repeatedly perhaps
to test to see whether or
not the password had been
changed and whether
the inventory was still live.
>> Was the webmail provider
a top tier one?
>> Yes.
>> Look, could it be
that they were just checking
the liveness of the account,
so that they can sell it?
>> Yes.
>> Verified account
with a working password.
>> That's the best hypothesis
I can think of for
the activity that we saw.
I thought we were going
to be able to watch
all this crazy stuff
going on with the account,
it wound up being
totally uninteresting.
>> What's special about M?
>> Yes. So there
are a couple where there's
just crazy stuff going
on in some of the accounts
and the time between
logins is very, very short.
I don't know.
One hypothesis is that
those credentials
were given to lots of
different people
and so you just saw
lots of different people
trying over time.
>> So the numbers
on the right are
they both unique email accounts
or unique websites?
>> The numbers on
the right are the number of
unique successful logins
to the email account
associated with these sites.
>> Under the same,
because I thought you registered
a lot of email accounts so
is it under the same account?
>> The same account.
So just to be very
concrete, for A,
we saw we had two accounts
and we saw two logins,
one to the easy,
one to the hard,
and then we never
saw logins again.
And then for N which had 570,
again we just had two accounts,
but we saw 570 logins
to those accounts.
>> Why did you not register
more hard and more
easy accounts?
Why did you just limit to one?
>> So it's a good question.
The value of registering
more would be
greater confidence
that the attackers
were just going through
an entire password database.
But the flip side is that
we wanted to minimize
harm so to speak to
the sites under question,
because we didn't
ask them if we could
register honey accounts with
them we were just doing that.
And so minimizing resources and
impact on them for
the work that we're doing,
lead us to minimize the number
of accounts that we have.
>> The reason I'm asking
this it's interesting
that one of them had
a lot of hard logins but
no single easy log in. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So one question I think,
you saw, look at M,
you saw the first
compromise around 6/16,
and you didn't warn
their site and they kept
compromising until 270.
>> Okay. So what I have not
plotted is when it
was that we notified.
For some of the sites,
it took us a little
while to notify.
And the reason why was
that the webmail provider
was doing this for us as
a favor and it required
somebody's time and
intervention to go in and
actually collect log data
and send it to us.
And that only
happened on occasion.
So there was a delay
in some times between
when we got it and when we
notified, things like that.
But it is also the case
that for some of the sites
we re-registered,
you know, for all these sites
we re-registered
new accounts to see
if there was
subsequent compromises.
And in some of the sites cases,
that didn't happen.
>> So did you do
any study of whether or not they
were mining the inboxes also?
>> We could not get information,
detailed information
about what they were
doing with the inbox
and we had not salted
the inbox with
that much information.
Because the challenge is we've
created 200,000 accounts
something like that,
and doing that at scale winds
up being very difficult.
We did create
realistic profiles for
all the individuals
with names, addresses,
all of that stuff was all valid,
but the inbox itself
was uninteresting.
>> What about outbox?
>> I'm sorry.
>> Outbox. Did they use you
to send email to somebody?
>> Some of them did.
And there were a couple where
they were sending
spam at such a rate
that automated systems
for the webmail provider
just shut down the account
even without our intervention.
But by and large,
there was very very little
activity out of your accounts.
I was expecting much more
but they were not being used.
So then, once we
had gathered this information
and then sort of
rolling over time,
when we discovered
a site was compromised,
we would notify the site
and we would look to try
to find the appropriate
contact addresses,
we would send them email
and wait for a response.
And whenever we got
a response and for
large sites we got
an immediate response,
not just from engineering
but also from legal.
And we were immediately
as helpful as possible
explaining what we did,
what we found,
all this kind of stuff.
But it led to some
interesting conversations
which provide some insight
into some of these sites.
So I'll just go
through some examples.
So I do want to
preface this that
there was a part of me that
was actually feeling pretty
bad when interacting
with these folks,
because we were telling them
that they had been compromised,
but we had no insight how or
why they were compromised.
All we could do was
to detect. It's like,
"You've been owned, good luck."
So it puts them in
a slightly awkward position.
Only a third of the sites
actually wound up
responding to us.
But all of the big sites well,
the majority of
the big sites did.
In the end though, even
based upon what we
were able to tell them,
no sites ever notified
users and no sites forced
a password reset on
the accounts at their site.
So it was not enough
to get them to do
anything and I'll
talk a little bit
more about that in the summary.
>> So when you are
notifying them,
did any of the sites
inform you that it was
against the policy for
you to even set up
such crap accounts.
>> No.
>>They should done
your job at all?
>> It could be that
the acceptable use policy
at the site said,
"Oh, you cannot use
an automated system to
register an account."
And then, when we notified them,
their response might be,
"Hey, what are you doing?
We told you, in our
acceptable use policy it says,
you are not supposed
to be doing that,
what are you doing?"
Nobody went down that path.
>> [inaudible] if I'm
a big company I really have
to take your word and say,
"Oh this counter was never used,
they are only storing here".
Right. I could
very well just say,
"You used it somewhere, and
it was leaked, not from us.
So why should I tell
the 100 million users
just because one of them?"
>> So we'll talk about
the top company in a second.
Okay. But, let's start small.
So going into this,
we fully expected that we
would find sites that were
well down the Alexa rankings,
that it's run by an individual
or small group of people.
It's not as if they have
a giant security team and
sure they would
likely have lots of
problems and sure enough yes,
we did run into those problems
and sites that had
those problems.
In interacting with them.
They would promise to fix
it soon but never took action.
The bottom line is they're
too busy fighting other fires.
So this was a great
anecdote from one of
the sites which was like,
"Look, when we started
this site I used
to have sysadmins,
but they kept on telling me that
I couldn't do things,
so I fired them all.
And that caused
even more problems for me."
Well, probably not surprising
that this occurred.
For the large sites,
they were very responsive
except for one.
And we heard from
different parts of the company
both engineering and legal.
And for the very top site,
the very big one,
we had multiple phone
calls with them,
where their lawyer just
asks us a long series
of questions.
And the idea behind
the questions, the goal
behind the questions,
was to try to find a weakness in
our methodology such
that they could point to
that as being
the explanation for
the account compromise not
to the site being breached.
Joe is fantastic
and handled that
questioning like a pro
and they could not
find a chink in the armor.
They still did not
corroborate that
there was a compromise.
The last question we
would ask is, well then,
what is another explanation
for all these that we found,
given everything
that we've discussed,
and they would never
answer the question.
So, for this Outdoor Site,
it was a Site that went
up being purchased by.
>> So there are some kind of
small companies that are go
ravaging around in the dark web,
find stuff on Pastebin,
and then contact companies
saying I've good evidence
that you've been
breached as a way of kind of
like trying to sell
their consulting stuff.
>> Yeah. FYI.
>> Yeah. Did anyone kind of
indicate or hint
that they might have
had because there's a chance
that there might have been
other channels that
this would feed backed?
>> Yes, one of the sites
knew they had been breached,
because somebody posted to
their forum saying, "Hey,
we breached and we
duplicated your entire site
and the alternate site
is running over
here in case you want to
come over and use us."
>> And there's
a separate kind of a,
maybe your stats is getting
kind of a little
because, you know,
at 19, but it would
be interesting to
see all those that are bridges
assuming all of these are.
What percent actually
end up on kind of
scriptable places like
Pastebin as opposed to,
I'm going to use
this for myself and
>> Yeah.
>> But the question
the efficacy of
those services because like for
example, like
Microsoft employees,
if you sign up for
the Legal Plan,
one of the things
that they offer is,
to tell you if your e-mail
account has been compromised.
And the way that
they do that is,
you enter your personal
e-mail address,
in my case it's
strategymobile.com
and then I regularly
get like reports from
them saying that,
we find a website where there
was your email address
and some password.
And I have no idea whether
that password is cracked or not.
>> And I would say the
lesson that we learned
from the small sites is,
even if they are notified
whether it's from
us or whether these
other channels,
it's a high enough
on our priority
to do something about it.
Their dealing with
other fires. Yeah.
>> So there's a database that
is called have I been
[inaudible] with a p.com.
>> Yes.
>> Or net or something and
that actually works
quite well because
I generally use
unique e-mail address
for all the sites
that I register with.
And they tell me like
when I elected one
of the Adobe one
and all the ones
that are known to
be compromised,
I've received a
notification through them.
So my question is,
have you considered
cross-referencing
your known hacked
accounts with that database?
>> Now that's a good question
and we didn't do it by have-
>> We can sign up.
>> Yeah, very good thing to
do. Yeah. It's good point.
Okay, so for this site,
the site was purchased
by a competitor in
a competing site.
And at the time
the site was handed
over to the competitor,
that is when we saw
the account being
accessed from the original site.
And so, who know you know
that might have been
an insider thing,
not necessarily an
external site breach,
who knows what was
going on there.
And then, for the very top one,
there's billion dollar company,
50 million users.
So we did have
extended conversations
with them over time.
After we had gone
through this, sort of,
entire methodology and
they couldn't find a flaw.
The next call that
we had with them
is they said that they had hired
a third party instant
rooflines team to review
everything and review
their internals.
And the third party team found
no indication of
site compromise.
But this was a site
that at the time that
our logins we observed
log in's to our accounts,
other users were
complaining on Twitter,
that their logins on
the site were compromised,
and there was even a story
in a newspaper about
it but the site
denied the allegations that
they would compromised.
So for this one actually we had
some additional external
validation that actually,
it wasn't just our accounts
who they were
compromising this time.
Okay. An interesting
side effect of these,
was that particularly
for this site,
I was sort of waiting for
something like this sort of
a legal document handed to
us and we did get
a Cease and Desist order.
But it wasn't from any of
the sites that we monitor.
It was from Tripwire Inc.,
who were very angry with
us for calling
our system Tripwire.
And it's like, it's just,
it's a name. We're not
commercializing it.
Okay. So, the technique works.
We did a pilot study found in
our roughly 19 compromised site,
one percent of the sites
that we were looking at it.
Compromisers were happening at
sites of all different scales.
The small ones not so surprising
but actually there were
large ones that didn't
have sort of the
greatest practices.
And none of this, none of
the sites did anything with
their users as a result of this.
And there's strong incentives
not to state that your site
has been compromised.
And so you can imagine
from their perspective,
if they had been
compromised, the risk,
the impact on stock prices
all of those kind of stuff of
declaring that versus sort
of a research team coming
in and saying look,
we have no other
explanation other
than your site has
been compromised with
no additional
information that they're
willing to take the risk to
say that it didn't happen.
>> So, earlier when you
talked about the difference
between hard and easy passwords,
the fact that somebody
would log in to one of
your hard password sites.
You said that that
indicated that the server
was potentially having
bad password practices,
but is that
necessarily the case?
In other words, once a site is
compromised depending on
the nature of the compromise,
I may be able to just
observe people logging in.
Admittedly, your
particular e-mail account
nobody would have logged
in but are you sure of it?
>> It can't be
absolutely certain.
So let's say it's the case
that somebody installs Malware,
at the other end
the HPS Connections are
actually able to see
that the authentication
happen in
real time as in our PC and
whatever, that's potentially.
We will not log in
to our accounts,
so they probably
wouldn't see ours.
So it's hard to have that be
an explanation for our accounts.
But that is very much
a limitation with
this technique which is,
it gives us no insight
into the compromise itself.
>> So the following question
is for sites that
are interested in detecting
their own compromise,
would you recommend
this technique to them?
>> Yes. Absolutely. Yeah.
OK. All right.
I clearly created way
too many sites but that's okay.
I'm going to transition
a little bit,
I've been talking about sort of
work that we've been
doing looking at DNS,
in particular the introduction
of the new top level domains.
And this is the work
that our student
Tristan did as part
of his dissertation.
There are sort of
two different stages
of this work and I will talk
a little bit about the first one
because I know already that
I am not going to be able
to do the second one.
All right, so, here's the idea,
where we were coming from
in starting this work.
DNS is absolutely critical
infrastructure for
the entire internet.
It is how we name
things on the internet.
But DNS domain names are
a particular way of being also
being very essential for
many different kinds of
large scale abuse and attacks.
There is value in having
domain names particularly
if they have reputation.
So, in a lot of
the work that we did,
we would look at
domains and the use of
domains sort of in the context
of a particular attack
but the introduction
in the new TLDs just
completely changes
the DNS landscape.
And so we wanted to
sort of get a sense for
how this change would
eventually impact
abuse and attacks.
And so we started
by just looking at
what was going on
with the new TLDs.
All right so that's
for some context.
Back when we were
in graduate school,
you had seven TLDs and
the country code TLDs.
Now, 1,200 new generic TLDs.
That is a lot. A lot.
OK. What's going on
with those new TLDs?
What are they being used for?
So, you know we wanted to
see to what extent, what,
what impact these new TLDs
are having on DNS and
are the introduction
of the new TLDs sort of
serving the pre-stated purpose
that they are introduced for.
Are they meeting unmet needs
that the lack of those TLDs had.
And our approach
to sort of doing
this foundation was to
examine one new TLD in detail
and then all new
TLDs that were registered
by the end of 2014.
So at the time of
this study it was 500 TLDs.
And we just look at all domains,
crawl their content,
so on and so forth.
And then our ongoing work
is sort of looking
at analyzing DNS from
a global perspective
to look for abuse and
attacks and weird ways in
which DNS is being used.
So I will focus
on this first one because it
is again a very
interesting story,
which is the XXX TLD.
It's an unusual TLD in
many ways and it has
a very storied history.
It's a TLD specialized
for adult content.
The registry that proposed
it was ICM Registry.
And they sort of
had a story for what
the value of the domain was
and all this kind of stuff.
But there was lots of criticism
all over the place and
actually even the adult
entertainment industry did not
want .XXX TLD to be created.
So, ICANN for various
reasons approved it in
2005 and then the
Governmental Advisory Council,
part of ICANN wrote a report
saying this is a terrible
idea, don't do it.
So ICANN said, "Oh, okay
fine, we won't do it".
So they rejected it and
then ICM Registry
filed a complaint,
an independent review board
upheld ICM Registry's complaint.
And so, ICANN said,
"Okay, I guess we have
to do it after all".
And then it became
active in 2011.
So, there was a story
for what XXX was for.
And it represents one of
these early new generic
top level domains.
And so we wanted to see
what was the impact of XXX.
So we would just enumerate
all the registered domains.
It turns out that
because of how XXX works,
it requires some inferences
not just sort of
enumerating the Zone file
although that's
one of the steps,
crawl the content and then based
upon what it is that we could
discover about that domain,
we tried to infer
the registration intent
of the domain in XXX.
Why did that person,
that individual
register that domain?
And then we would also
estimate the costs and
the revenue as a result of
the domain registrations
to ICM Registry.
How much money is ICM Registry
making as a result?
Okay. The registration
process for this,
winds up being
unusually complicated.
There are these
things, it started
with this Rollout Period,
and so ICM Registry
since it was a new
opening up new territory,
new name territory,
it wanted to try to
capitalize on new names
being available.
And so it had a premium for
people to register new names.
So some, one part of
that premium is for people who
might want domains
in XXX at Sunrise A.
And then there are people who
don't want to have
domains in XXX.
And so there was another period
where you could pay
money so that nobody else
could grab that domain for you.
So in this period Microsoft
could register Microsoft.XXX,
so that nobody
else could register
Microsoft.XXX for
obvious reasons.
And then, there is
a whole set of names
that are protected.
So for example all U.S.
presidents, senators,
congressmen.
All of their names are
protected, can't register them.
And then finally after
all this auctioning,
all this crazy stuff happening,
then they open it up to
sort of general registrations.
And then these are,
these are the prices
for registering
the domain. All right.
So what we wanted to do is
we wanted to enumerate
all the domains of XXX,
crawl them, find out and
then eventually try
to infer the intent.
Zone file gives you
all the domains that
are registered and resolving.
And then there are bunch
of names that are hidden.
They're not in the Zone file.
They're just hidden
because they're
reserved or non-resolving,
things like that.
And so we would have to sort
of infer counts and guess
at what these domains
might be to
try to get a sense
of the numbers there.
For the domains where
we could crawl them.
We downloaded
both their web content,
of course all of
their DNS records
as well as WHOIS records,
and try to use this as a way
for inferring
registration intent.
So this is what happens if
you go to Microsoft.XXX.
You get this page
that pops up that says
this domain has been
a reserve from registration.
So Microsoft paid $200 in
Sunrise B so that nobody
else could register XXX.
Microsoft.XXX,
including Microsoft.
So Microsoft cannot
use this domain.
Alright. And this web page
is served out of
ICM Registry which is
a registry that owns XXX.
So the intent here
is to reserve names
and essentially protect you
from other people
registering it.
There is another way
in which sites,
organizations,
people can protect
themselves from other people
registering them.
And it's, the categories called
Registered Non-Resolving.
So for example, if
you look up UCSD.XXX.
So we pay money,
UCSD pays money to
ICM registry for UCSD.XXX,
you get a non-existent domain.
So UCSD pays money
on a yearly basis
to ICM Registry so that
if anybody tries to
look it up it says the domain
is non-existent and roughly
speaking- so you
can't enumerate these,
there's no way to enumerate
them because they're
not in the Zone file
or anything like that.
And so you have to try to sort
of guess what their,
what their numbers are.
And roughly speaking,
the amount in this category,
at least in the first year
is roughly speaking
the same amount in
the reserved category
like Microsoft's case.
And the intent here is
clearly to be defensive.
You don't want somebody else
registering it so you're willing
to pay money so that they can't.
And then there are
two other categories,
one is speculative.
So these are people
who are registering
domains because
they believe that
they'll be able to sell it at
a higher price to
somebody else who
wants it down the line.
So parking pages, so this is
an example of a parking page
of a domain in XXX.
They are just, it's up there,
the domain that has
been registered.
It resolves, if you visit it in
the browser, they just
want to sell it to you.
So it's just pure speculation.
And then the other is primary,
this is actual content,
and I didn't show a screen
shot for obvious reasons.
So do the enumeration,
do the crawl. Look
at everything.
We know what the costs are
for each of all of
the registrations,
all of this kind of
stuff and then we could
just multiply everything out.
You get a table that
looks like this.
So we have these four
categories of the intent
for which people were
doing the registrations.
The number of domains that
were in that category,
and then multiplying
by the cost,
the amount of money, the revenue
that ICM Registry received.
So, impressively 24 million to
ICM Registry just in
the initial period for
people defending their names.
They are just minting money.
All right.
And then if you look
at the recurring
costs these are the yearly,
so doing the reserve in sort of
the initial registration
where you pay
$200 so that nobody else
could use it forever.
That's just a onetime cost.
But the UCSD's case where
they are doing the registry,
registered non-resolving,
UCSD is paying a
$100 a year to ICM Registry
so that nobody else can
register that domain.
And the recurring costs
for the revenue that is
coming to ICM Registry,
less than 10 percent of
it is due to people who
actually have
adult content in XXX.
So it's just a scam.
Just a big scam.
All right. So, does XXX
meet the unmet needs?
Absolutely not. Huge scam.
What-ever adult content is
in XXX or is out
on the internet.
It is not in XXX.
You have to go elsewhere
if you want to find it.
But a huge cost
to everybody else.
So clearly, a failure from
the perspective of why
it is that we might
introduce a new TLD.
So, then we did it
for all new TLDs.
So, ICANN opened up
the process of registering
for new TLDs in January 2012.
Anybody could go out
there and register a TLD.
We were really excited and we
are starting the process when we
realize that there's
$200,000 cost for doing it,
which is even too steep for us.
But anybody can do it,
there are lots of
different categories,
it was very controversial
at the time.
The good is that it opens
up vast new name spaces.
Beyond just the crowded .com,
but of course that might
introduce confusion,
add cost, result in
legal battles,
all this kind of stuff.
So, lots of debate
about whether this was
actually a good idea.
So we wanted to sort of see,
evaluate you know for
all of these new ones,
what is going on
inside the new TLDs?
Okay. What I'm going to do.
So same methodology,
roughly speaking
of XXX except we can't go
into as much detail
because we have
500 TLDs in all of
the hundreds of thousands of
domains that are
registered in all of them.
Okay. But, I'll just
sort of summarize
what the results were.
So, do the new TLDs
meet unmet needs?
Well, clearly there is
a demand for a new TLDs.
The fact that we now have
1,200 new generic TLDs,
people were really excited
about registering new TLDs.
It is expensive and
we developed a sort
of a profit model
for these new TLDs.
How many registrations
do you need
over how much time before
you become profitable?
And actually it's not
clear that the majority are
actually going to be
profitable down the line.
So, there has to be
other reasons why
they're registering
these new TLDs.
There was not a deluge
of sort of lawsuits or
confusion over domains spanning
one TLD versus another.
Certainly there are
some organizations
that are protecting themselves.
Microsoft would be one of them.
You register Microsoft.star
and just do that.
Customers are using them.
So, in the top TLDs,
hundreds of thousands of new
domains are being registered.
And, we did
this machine learning analysis
where we asked the question,
is the content on the site
of the domain registered
in the new TLD related to
the name of the new TLD?
And when there is content,
interestingly, 80 percent
of the time it was.
So for .New York,
New York related websites;
.London, London
related websites.
So to that extent actually,
it seemed to be
working out fine.
But if you sort of look
at all the registrations,
it is still the case that
defensive dominates
actual content.
So, only 15 percent
of the domains
that we were able to crawl,
had real content on them.
The other were either defensive,
lets say, redirects or
something like that,
or they were speculative.
Lots of lots of parking
out there in the new TLDs.
>> Does the 15 percent
that's new,
are they replicating content
that's already on the .com or
something or is it
genuinely new, new, new?
>> Generally new,
new, new. So we
tried to take in account
for that if there is
a redirect or if
it was similar to
the .com version than
we'd say not new. Yeah.
>> If I paid $200,000
to open the TLD,
what kind of right do I have?
>> Oh, okay. Right.
So the business model
is that as a registry,
you're going to own
a new TLD [inaudible] .
Now you will engage in
business contracts with
registrars like GoDaddy.
GoDaddy will sell
domains in [inaudible] .
And you get to set
what the price is.
GoDaddy will take a sliver of
every domain registration and
then you get the remainder.
Yeah, ICANN also
gets a little too.
Okay. And then, you know,
this is still sort of the basis
of ongoing work at looking
at various kinds of abuse
but being able to do it.
Now that we have all this
infrastructure being able to
crawl sort of DNS at scale,
of looking at abuse
in DNS at scale.
>> So, I'm still surprised on
how much new content
there seems to be.
Did you compare it
against everything
else or did you just compare
it against things with
the same name .com?
>> So we compared it
against the same name .com.
We also, at the time
that we were
crawling all of the new domains
that were appearing
in the new TLDs,
we also crawled
new registrations in .com,
to sort of see you know what is
the fraction of parked pages
in the new TLDs relative to
the new parked pages in
.com, things like that.
And it was absolutely
the case that there was
far more defensive and
speculation in the new TLDs
for new registrations
relative to .com,
relative to content.
There was more new content
was occurring in .com at
the same time that
some content was
appearing in the new TLDs.
And these percentages are for
domains that actually had
a web server respond
to an HTTP request.
So there are lots of
domain, registered domains,
in the new TLDs
that don't resolve,
or there's some kind of error,
or there's a web error
or something like that.
This is just for
where we actually had
content and can look at it.
All right. I'll stop there.
So this is still, you know,
an area in which
we're very active and
working not just
sort of DNS abuse
but sort of current projects
we are looking at
account compromised
by attackers.
You paid attacker $100,
you give them an email address,
like victorball@microsoft.com
and then they will
give you the password for
victorball@microsoft.com.
Yeah. Exactly. Ad fraud,
looking at security outcomes,
OSN abuse, phishing, looking at,
you know, VPNs are now being
advertised pretty,
pretty heavily.
Do VPNs actually give you
the guarantees that they
advertise to give you?
Are they storing
stuff and reselling,
you know, interesting
questions there.
>> Are you going to include
Facebook in that study?
Because they're now
offering a VPN service
It would be good for
the privacy sensitive
user who doesn't
want their online activity
to be viewed by
a large corporation.
>> Facebook already knows
everything about you.
So if you use them as VPN,
they're not going to
learn anything new.
So, I mean, once you signed
up, game over already.
>> What is lateral phishing?
>> Lateral phising is,
I'm able to phish
an account in a company.
And then based upon
that phished account,
then go and compromise
other accounts or other servers.
So, it has become clear,
so if you ever look at sort
of how breaches happen
in practice so if you
were to sort of let's say be
a legal consultant
on a case where
there are breaches
under dispute,
the methodology actually is,
you just get a toe-hold
anywhere in the company.
And then once you get
that toe-hold then you
become very clever in trying
to then find
the actual resources
that you're after when
you're compromising that.
That's it. And in fact,
it's the lateral step
that is very much
understudied. That we're
trying to get a handle on.
>> Is there a study on
online social network abuse?
>> All right. So, this is
actually a project we
just submitted to using
security last week.
It's completely crazy.
I'm not an online
OSN user myself, but,
so imagine you have
an online social network
and there are
various metrics about
your OSN account,
how many people follow you?
How many people like you?
All this kind of stuff.
Okay. There are services out
there that you pay
them and they will
increase those metrics.
And we're talking,
and these services,
let's say they're making a lot
of money from doing this.
A lot, a lot of money.
>> I have a personal experience,
my wife has a business,
so I have this experience how
they do it and how bad it is.
>> So, the goal
of the project is
to enroll in the services
using honey-pot accounts,
understand how it
is that they work,
based upon that understanding
create essentially
signatures so you can
monitor at scale for
the entire service.
Look at how the service
operates at scale.
Look at how much money
they're making,
and then use the knowledge
gained to intervene
and shut them down.
And, in this case we
actually looked at
different interventions
over time to see
how services react to
different interventions.
>> How about letting on,
like there are services
that use these,
like there are people who
use these services and
so learning that these people
had used that service.
>> We did not go down
that path but that would be
another way of getting
more information about
how the service works.
Yes. It's just amazing
that the ecosystem that
is built up around this,
on metrics they don't
actually mean anything.
>> Do you think,
all these chatter around
password-less authentication,
how do you see that space?
And, you know going
forward with passwords
still can't be repeated.
Down which way,
whichever which way?
>> Unfortunately yes.
>> You would say, yes?
>> I don't see passwords
going away anytime soon.
>> Is that because
the other schemes are
too clunky or very expensive?
>> Well, it comes back again
to this usability question.
Nobody wants security.
Users don't want security,
sites don't want security,
the attackers don't want
security, nobody wants security.
And because it only makes
things more of a hassle,
and it's this hassle
slash convenience factor
about sort of two
factor authentication
and things like that
that I would say
has limited the
adoption rate of it.
You know, if you're
a small group
creating your site for
other people to use,
you just don't- it's not
where you're trying to
focus all your time.
Now, one way in which you
can sort of adopt it is that,
you can then let
Microsoft or Google or
Facebook authenticate for you.
But then those companies
get insight into
your site as well.
So there is a little bit of
trade-off going on there.
But, having the big sites
authentic for you seems like
the greatest hope for
small sites adopting
more sophisticated
authentication techniques.
They're not going to do
it themselves. But, yeah,
passwords I still see them,
see them here for quite a while.
All right. Well,
thank you very much.
I really appreciate it.